-"Fox News" and the GOP
have been struggling
to criticize President Biden's
coronavirus response,
including his $1.9 trillion
relief bill,
because it's been overwhelmingly
popular with voters.
So now they're insisting
he give his predecessor
credit for the vaccine.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
It's an awkward time
for "Fox News,"
arguably their biggest star
wasn't any of their anchors,
but the 45th president himself.
The guy called into Fox News
more often than a Mets fan
calling into a sports radio show
to complain
about the off season.
[ As fan ] Look, I know we have
a new billionaire owner
that we signed ten free agents
and made seven trades,
but do we really think orange
and blue looked good together?
I'll hang up and listen.
[ Normal voice ] The point is,
Trump was Fox's big star
in defending him was
their number one mission.
Now, without that,
they're a little at sea.
They've spent the past few weeks
in full meltdown mode
over everything from
"The Muppets" to "Dr. Seuss"
to "Mr. Potato Head,"
to the "Looney Tunes,"
to Joy Bahar,
to the Grammys,
to defending Piers Morgan
after he stormed off
the set of his own show
like a guest on "Maury"
who won't accept the results
of a paternity test.
They can't defend Trump
and they can't effectively
criticize Biden.
So they've been lurching
from one dumb culture war issue
to the next.
They know Biden's COVID response
has been overwhelmingly popular
and the COVID relief bill
has even been popular
with Republican voters.
Fifty nine percent of whom say
they support the COVID bill.
So remember that when people say
it's not bipartisan, it is.
It's just that no Republican
politician supported it.
Also, let me just say
as a side note,
no one gives [Bleep]
if it's bipartisan,
people care much more about
results than bipartisanship.
Polls have borne
that out repeatedly.
Do you think a family of four
would have been happier
if instead of $12,000
in stimulus money
and child benefits,
they got a much crappier bill
that had Republican support?
[ As spouse 1 ] Well, honey,
our unemployment benefits
are expiring a month earlier
and it's only a $600 check,
but Susan Collins voted for it.
[As spouse 2] We got Collins?
[As spouse 1]We got Collins!
well off
to work a triple shift.
In fact, even when "Fox News"
does try to latch on
to something Biden said,
they melt down
over the most insignificant
bull[Bleep]
because it's all they have.
For example, they obsessed
over the fact that
in his prime time address
last week,
Biden suggested that
if we keep wearing masks
and get as many people
vaccinated as possible,
we might be able to safely
have July 4th barbecues
with friends
and families this year.
And in response,
Fox pundits lost their mind.
-The message that Joe Biden
was sending
to the American people
was a lecture.
It was a demand that basically
said you'll only be able
to have a 4th of July
if you go along
with all the different things
that I say you have to do.
-We might be getting back to
normal around the Fourth of July
if only we all behave.
-Well, I hate
to tell Joe Biden,
but nobody needs his permission
to gather in our backyards
on the Fourth of July
or any holiday or any day,
for that matter.
-He's got no say in who's
coming to my picnic or yours.
-He does not have
my permission
to give me permission.
-Right.
-About who I can have
a barbecue with.
-Yes. This is a free people.
This is a free country.
How dare you tell us who we can
spend the Fourth of July with.
-To pick Independence Day
as the day where he says
he might allow people to gather
is just so un-American.
And, and just, you know,
Joe Biden doesn't get to tell me
when I can have a barbecue
in my backyard.
-He's not!
You're all free
to do whatever you want
with whoever you want
in your backyard.
I invite all of you to go
to Tucker's house
for a barbecue where I'm sure
he puts out Coors Light
and then drinks the Sam Adams
you brought.
Sane people knew
what Biden was saying.
Most people have been following
public health advice
because they don't want to get
their friends and family sick
and vice versa.
But if we all do our part,
we can safely gather again
this summer.
It wasn't a directive.
It wasn't a mandate.
It wasn't an executive order.
It was just a suggestion
like you should wear a helmet
on your motorcycle
or don't eat raw chicken.
But over at "Fox News,"
whose slogan might as well be
"We run with scissors," they're
so desperate to play the victim,
they'll take even
the mildest suggestion
and try to turn it into
a don't tread on me moment.
We all know the type,
the people who fall apart
when they see
no substitutions on a menu.
[ Whiny voice ] Oh, but I had my
heart set on a BLP --
bacon, lettuce, and potato.
[ Normal voice ] Now it will
shock you to learn
that this criticism of Biden
has not stuck either.
So now they're on
to another line,
slamming him for not giving
Trump credit for the vaccines.
-The Biden administration
continues to refuse to share
any credit
on vaccine development
with former President Trump.
-President Biden did not utter
President Trump's name once
during his first solo address.
He didn't give President Trump
any credit, even though
President Trump
rolled back regulations
and, of course,
introduced Warp Speed
to get those vaccines
on the market.
-I loved how he took credit
for what
President Trump has been doing
as far as the vaccine
and getting it roll it out.
But no one called him out on it.
-No Trump, no vaccine, Joe, stop
taking credit for something,
frankly,
you had nothing to do with.
He could talk about
operation warp speed,
how we exceeded expectations.
And we don't need to go over
the 500,000 dead.
We had that moment.
Let's talk about
the future moving forward.
Every time he has a chance
to praise
the previous administration,
he not only doesn't praise,
he kicks him in the groin.
-I mean, first of all,
Biden doesn't need to kick
Trump in the groin
because he already looks like
he just got kicked in the groin.
He leans forward
like he just took
a tennis ball
in the nut[Bleep].
The ball machine's
on the lowest setting.
He didn't even move his racket.
Sometimes he looked like
he's about
to get kicked in the groin,
like when he sits with his legs
spread far apart,
like he's in an episode
of "Jackass" bracing for
a game of nutball.
Let's not, let's just not gloss
over it.
The heartless,
sociopathic dismissal
of the fact that over half
a million people died.
You're talking about a
once-in-a-century catastrophe
full of misery and death,
like the taskmaster
at the weekly book club.
Okay, Barbara, we don't need
to go over, "Eat, Pray, Love,"
that was last week.
Let's talk about this week's
book, "Green Eggs and Ham."
[ Whispering ] It's just the
cover of "Green Eggs and Ham"
the inside is
"McElligot's Pool."
And not only do Fox hosts want
Biden to give Trump
credit publicly,
they also want him
to call Trump personally
to thank him.
-Joe Biden, he needs
to pick up the phone,
I suggest call
Mar a Lago and yeah,
bring unity to the country as
he says he so desperately wants.
And thank
President Donald Trump.
-Is it Mara Largo?
[ Laughs ]
I guess I've been saying
it wrong.
So tune in for Sean Hannity's
correction this week.
Oh, really? You think
you should call Mar a Lago?
First of all,
have you seen Trump lately?
I doubt you have to call him.
He looks so ghostly you can
probably use a Ouija board.
He looks like he's haunting
the golf course.
The "Legend of Haggard Vance,"
[ As Trump ] "You summoned me?"
[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, Don, Listen.
[ As Trump ] Can I get
a diet Coke?
[ Normal voice ] Sure.
I just wanted to --
[ As Trump ] Mind if I crash
here tonight?
Mel doesn't want me around.
Says it keeps
giving her the creeps
by passing through walls.
[ Normal voice ] Although there
seems to be some tension
at Fox over whether Trump
deserves credit
for this miraculous
medical breakthrough
that will save the world
or whether the vaccines
are actually part of a sinister
plot to do something bad.
It's not clear what,
but don't worry.
Human Catamaran Tucker Carlson
is on the case.
-How effective is this
coronavirus vaccine?
How necessary is it
to take the vaccine?
Don't dismiss those questions
from anti-vaxxers,
don't kick people off
social media for asking them,
answer the questions.
-How effective is
this vaccine?
How necessary is it
to take the vaccine?
Will it make you an X man?
Or what about an Animorph?
Will it make me half man,
half porcupine?
And if I go to the mall
with my children
after taking the vaccine
and I get spooked
by one of the mannequins
at the Tommy Bahama store
and shoot my quills
at a security guard,
will they throw me out?
Will my children laugh at me?
What if I say it's because
the vaccine turned me
into a porky man
and they say, "Sir, you didn't
shoot quills at anyone.
You urinated on
the chambray beach shorts."
And I say, "Oh, so now I can't
urinate wherever I want.
I thought this was America and I
thought America was number one."
And then I urinate again
because the vaccine also
took away my bladder control.
All these questions
have already been answered.
You could save yourself
the trouble of writing
your nightly monologue
by just using Google,
although maybe
he doesn't know how,
that would explain why he always
looks like Templeton the Rat
trying to read Charlotte's Web.
Some pig? What kind of pig
are we talking about?
A wild boar or just
a standard farm pig?
I'm just asking questions.
The trial data, which was
reviewed extensively
by public health officials,
have shown all three vaccines
to be highly safe and effective,
especially against severe
disease and hospitalization.
And there's still more
real world data
coming in all the time.
New studies testing the efficacy
of the vaccines on variants
or in specific settings
like nursing homes
and suggesting they could
even be highly effective
at stopping transmission
as well.
And it's necessary to take
the vaccine
if, say,
you're not Tucker Carlson
and you can't do
your cushy TV job
from the safety
of your studio bubble,
where I'm certain no one's
allowed within six feet of you,
even when there isn't
a pandemic,
because they might accidentally
make eye contact
and have their soul devoured.
Some people actually
have to go out into the world
and do real jobs for a living,
where they're forced to interact
with other people,
which puts them at risk.
And they don't have the luxury
of getting the same
high end medical care
that, say, Donald Trump got
when he got COVID.
And I say that
as a fellow TV show host
who is constantly tested
for COVID,
this job is easy compared
to most people's jobs.
How about you try working
in a meatpacking plant
or a nursing home or
a public school for a few days?
The hardest thing I ever
have to do is tell Wally
he doesn't have any lines
in tonight's show.
-I just bought a new car, Seth,
I really need to check.
-Hey, hey, hey.
What did I say, Wally?
That doesn't count, does it?
It does?!
[ Groans ]
Also, we need as many people
as possible to get vaccinated
so we can reach herd immunity,
get to the point where the virus
isn't just freely circulating
and sparking constant
outbreaks,
which would allow us to get back
to our normal lives safely.
Even Donald Trump
told his supporters on Fox News
last night
to get the vaccine,
although, of course, he was also
desperate to claim credit,
especially after being egged on
by UNcancel Looney Tune
Maria Bartiromo.
-How are you feeling tonight
about the fact
that you're not getting
any credit for any of this
by the Biden administration?
-So when you go to when you go
to the COVID issue,
we did a great job. We get very
little credit for it.
I was the one
and this administration
was the one
that came up with a vaccine.
-No, you weren't.
The scientist did it.
The development
of the Pfizer vaccine,
the first one approved
by the FDA,
it wasn't even a part
of Operation Warp Speed.
And I'm sorry, but I just can't
imagine you in a lab tinkering
with a microscope
and some test tubes.
You would last five minutes
in a lab
before you set your tie
on fire with a Bunsen burner
and tried to put it out
with alcohol.
All Trump did was say
make a vaccine.
Trump's initial vaccine rollout
was a disaster.
FEMA didn't start setting up
mass vaccination sites
until Biden was president,
before he left office,
Trump's White House even lobbied
to deny states money
for the vaccine rollout.
And when he had the chance
to buy more vaccine, he passed.
Biden's the one who inked deals
to produce more vaccine,
pushed through a relief bill
that provided immediate funding
for vaccinations
and got two rivals,
Merck and Johnson & Johnson,
to work together
to ramp up production.
Can you imagine
Trump doing that?
First of all,
he probably thinks
Merck is the new
Vin Diesel movie.
And Johnson & Johnson
is a personal injury law firm
that advertises on local TV
in Palm Beach.
[ As Trump] Hello.
Is this Johnson & Johnson?
I need a lawyer to defend me
in multiple
criminal investigations.
My old lawyer fell asleep
on the F train,
and when he woke up,
he accidentally transferred
to the cyclone.
[ As Guiliani ] I guess this
one's the express.
[ Normal voice ] "Fox News,"
Oh, my God, I have fully
We might need makeup,
I Giuliani'd myself.
"Fox News" and the GOP
don't have a coherent criticism
of the Biden administration's
pandemic response.
So they've turned instead to a
mix of paranoia,
culture war B.S.,
vaccine conspiracy theories,
and, of course,
grotesque racism,
warning of more so-called
caravans at the border
and allowing Trump to repeat a
vile anti-Asian slur
last night
when referring to the pandemic
even as anti-Asian hate crimes,
especially against women,
have skyrocketed.
This is a time
when we need to support,
stand in solidarity with
the Asian-American community
and condemn virulent racists
who repeat vile slurs
that lead to hate crimes
instead of giving the maritime
on television.
And we need to call them
what they are hate crimes.
And as for the GOP
and Fox News,
whenever someone politely
suggests wearing a mask
or taking the vaccine,
tells them to stop being racist,
they need to stop acting
like they've been kicked --
-In the groin.
-This has been "A Closer Look.
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button,
stay safe, wear a mask,
get vaccinated. We love you.